let's cut right to the chase Wow these
are of my house shoes yeah you are you
are stylin I mean everything's going
your way and nothing says it like those
so I got these men you know I always
worked Gucci shoes and stuff but I had
to they black people told me to stop
wearing Gucci so we had to stop with
white well I can't remember why black
people had to stop wearing good because
well well I'm still gonna wear to Gucci
our guy but I can't I came by new right
now you know like this one black dudes
like what you doing we're Gucci and I'm
like you could take me shopping if you
want to like about some more stuff but
no Gucci did something and I'm just
refresh my memory let me show you I
think got some pictures of some shoe in
trouble no way the sweater oh look at
that oh my god look this is I think Katy
Perry's mine look at her shoes yeah no
black people look like that a noose wow
this is Burberry yeah see I think what
they need they need to hire a black
person to go oh that's what they need
what you're saying you're saying you can
tell that there's honey and any of these
is not one black person there's no black
people working at any one black person
to go uh he need an office and assistant
everything his whole job
[Music]
[Laughter]
would you would you be up for that job
would you yeah actually I did it before
when I was working here I stopped a lot
of Conan I made this because other
stuff they had look oh you what you you
tried to you wanted to update our is
that records look at our barracks yeah
[Applause]